c'est un procès exceptionnel qui s'est
ouvert ce matin à reims d'abord parce
qu'il s'agit d'un procès en révision
il n'y en a eu que six depuis un siècle
ensuite parce que l'accusé patrick dils
qui a déjà purgé 14 ans en prison va
tenter de prouver son innocence dans un
double meurtre d'enfant
les débats se déroulent à huis clos sur
place clément weill raynal et salah
graby pourquoi lors de son arrestation
il ya 15 ans patrick dils avait-il avoué
être le meurtrier des deux enfants cyril
et alexandre dont les corps avaient été
retrouvés le long de cette voie ferrée
non loin du domicile de la famille 10
des aveux répété à de nombreuses
reprises notamment devant le juge
d'instruction
quinze ans plus tard derrière les portes
de la cour d'assises de reims où se
tient le procès à huis clos
c'est la grande question qui domine les
débats dès l'ouverture de l'audience
patrick dils aurait évoqué les
circonstances dans lesquelles il était
passé aux aveux
est ce qui s'est dit ce matin ils ont
fait parler mon fils qu'est ce qu'il a
dit qui est couplé pas coupable c'est
tout voilà forcé de faire les gestes il
a fait qu'il a forcé d'après vous la
police à l'époque patrick dils n'avait
que 16 ans il était un adolescent
particulièrement immature et fragile
presque un enfant mais aujourd'hui
encore bernard varlet le policier qui
avait mené l'interrogatoire se souvient
de la garde à vue du jeune garçon
il est sous la coupe d'un officier de
police judiciaire
il doit répondre aux questions qu'on lui
et qu'on lui pose est est pas libre de
ses mouvements
c'est pour ça qu'il est en garde à vue
mais les pressions comme en volume qu
exercent des pressions que dante quand
dans le même temps dans le bureau voisin
se trouvent des personnes honorables mon
avis quelques le procureur de la
république
la juge d'instruction une psychologue le
patron de l'antenne de police judiciaire
de metz le directeur du cv joël de
police judiciaire de strasbourg
seulement voilà la police avait réussi
durant l' enquête à obtenir les aveux de
deux adultes dont cet homme aujourd'hui
témoin au procès ces deux suspects
furent par la suite mis hors de cause
la défense attend de leurs témoignages
qu'ils éclairent la cour sur la manière
dont furent mener les interrogatoires
autre témoin très attendu au procès y
sera interrogé lundi le tueur en série
francis heaulme dont la présence sur les
lieux du crime à justifier la révision
du procès un procès qui se tient donc à
huit clos et dont on ignore la teneur
exacte des débats les jurés rendront
leur verdict à la fin de la semaine
prochaine